hi
i'm chelsea kara kosova i'm a product
manager for stem math products at
pearson
and i'm based in boston hi i'm mike from
silva
a zurich based edtech startup using
wolfram technologies
in our presentation we show how silva
helps pearson
to create interactive math exercises
i work at pearson as a product manager
on our mylab
math platform which currently serves
millions of students
in the us and worldwide
mylab math is a fully featured content
and assessment platform
students come here to read the e-text
do practice homework and even take
high-stakes assessment
where we do see a bit of a gap is
in our assessment questions we have a
bank for each title of thousands of
questions that consist
of multiple choice free response drag
and drop
interactive video but we have
a consistent request from faculty to
drive conceptual
understanding and to really promote
engagement with students
to get away from rote memorization
that they're likely to forget next week
and that's why i've decided to pilot
some silver powered exercises in our
products this fall
and i'd like to show you a little bit
more about why
so what you're seeing on screen is from
the calculus e-text completely composed
in mathematica by briggs
cochrane-gillette
and schultz and this is a replacement
for the traditional paper
book and students come here to
learn the concepts and then they would
go to my lab math to work on
homework assessment so here is chapter
three on derivatives so as they're
reading
the narrative text interspersed with
practice
there are hundreds of these interactive
figures woven throughout the narrative
and for this example we have a graph of
the derivative
and we've got some really lovely tangent
lines
illustrating the concept to students
and as i say there are hundreds of these
baked throughout the narrative text
and if you see it suggests related
exercises 17 to 18.
so if we hop over to the mylab we see
what that question looks like rendered
in the mylab currently
we have a static image and a multiple
choice
selection for students this is just not
nearly as
interactive as the experience they were
just having in the e-text
and doesn't encourage conceptual deep
understanding of the concept so let's
take a look at what this question could
look like
using silva here we have the same
concept
illustrated only now students are
interactively asked to graph
f prime by moving these locator points
these types of questions compared to
what we just saw in the mylab with the
multiple choice really drive home the
concept of the tangent line
and slope to students more than a
multiple choice question
ever could let's look at another example
here we are back in the mathematica
e-text and this time we're in chapter
5 learning about area functions so once
again
students are presented with narrative
and the opportunity
to see the concepts in action using
these interactive figures
to essentially learn by doing back in
the mylab this
is an example a representative example
of the types of exercises that would be
available
for this concept so we have a static
figure
where students are asked to find and
graph the area function
which they would need to do on their own
piece of paper
and enter a free response
here followed by
a multiple choice piece where they're
matching
now let's take a look at what this looks
like as a silver exercise
here students are given the chance to
interact and create the graph
by moving these locator points once
again
they're able to see an immediate impact
of
their actions on the graph
they're invited to play around with it
and are all in all more engaged and
hopefully
obtaining some of that elusive
conceptual understanding that is a
consistent
request from instructors you'll notice
that this is
um placed into a pearson ui so this
exercise would sit along others in
a student's homework they're able to
check their answer
receive immediate feedback
and once they're satisfied with their
answer
they would save and submit this would be
scored alongside
all of those hundreds and thousands of
exercises that we currently have in the
my lab
so you would as an instructor you would
be able to create an assignment that
did have some skill and drill exercises
perhaps a video assignment
mixed in with some of these interactive
style questions
some skill maintenance style questions
so you could devise an assignment
that was more than just drilling the
skills from a particular section
you would give students the opportunity
to watch a little
do a little learn a little
thanks chelsea we are really excited to
collaborate with pearson
to make math exercises more engaging
it's great to see what the psn author
has already achieved with silva
and today i want to show you a few more
insights on how it works how we set up
questions and grading
let me start by highlighting four main
features silva offers to authors
number one is interactivity
let's look at the example we've seen
earlier
here the authors took full advantage of
all the powerful features mathematica
offers
such as creating dynamic interfaces
in combination with graphs
and with that they created a truly
interactive experience for the students
as they move the locators the slope
of the black lines would immediately
adjust
this is interactivity
now imagine a student would like to
exercise a little more
then it would be really boring if they
would always get the exact same
question and for that
we offer parametrization and
randomization
that is creating different
but similar versions of one and the same
question
here the task is the same but the
numbers change
the graph is mirrored and so on
this is parametrization and
randomization
number three is the autograding
let's try to solve this question
as i move the locator i see here now
the black line is tangent
and as we know the derivative
of a quadratic function
is a linear function so let me
try to get this right
all right let's check our answer
and it's correct we get
an additional explanation
you found the derivative function for
gradient quadratic function the
derivative is
always a linear function now this is
autograding
what is really important for the
learning experience
are the cases where the student doesn't
get it right
so imagine they would forgot
to move the first locator
let's try this
now they get a feedback that is
incorrect
but with a tailored explanation
the first point is not correct yet make
sure the black line is tangent
to the blue curve and that you get a
straight red line
now let's do this
and now we see third case it's
created as partially correct so it's
almost right
but outside of the error tolerance we
defined
and of course that can be fully
customized
that's number four tailored feedback
and now you may wonder how do we create
such persons
etc well we want to equip all educators
with some mathematical knowledge with a
tool
that they can create such questions
and for this purpose we created creo
creo is silva's authoring tool
it's an add-on to mathematica and once
you install it
it will be available through the
palettes menu
it takes care of all notebooks and files
and questions and so on
so that you don't need to worry about it
now let's look at the notebook that
created the question we have seen
earlier
number one is graph an area function
here you can see that once
the dynamic content gets a little more
deep
the code also will get a little longer
here is the second example we have seen
a little bit shorter
and here you also see the grading
but let's start with something easy
something from scratch
when you create a new question it will
just look like this
so assume you started with prototyping
in the mathematica notebook
here we have a dynamic module that
includes
a simple locator pane some disk
and now we want to turn this into a
question
how can we do that
we simply copy and paste the code
into creo we want
that it's an interactive question
so copy and paste
that's it now what kind of question
could we ask about it
we could some say something like
find the green disk
okay and now we need to look at the
grading
here we defined a point
and this is dynamic so this will be our
locator later
so what we can do is just say
the point
needs to be smaller than
0.5 and since we are interested in the x
coordinate
for the first on that all right
now let's preview this
so here we go we have a question
find the green disk and we can move the
locator
and point it here to the green disk
and we will get a correct
now if we do this again
we get the exact same question
and if we don't get it right
it will simply be incorrect
okay now let's try to
inject the parametrization here
in this case will be easy to just
use different colors so
let me replace the green with color
and add the parameter we call this
parameter color
and make it
a custom list of colors
red blue green and so on
now we want to inject this into
our interactive interface
so we replace the green by
template slot
and then simply color
now in order that
those colors get recognized
we add the capitalize and to
expression in front all right
let's test this now
we see that we get immediately a
different version
so now it picked pink one and created
the nice color this
so let's try another version
and we get the blue one
so we injected the parametrization
and randomization but we still have
on the kind of black white grading
either you get it right or you get it
wrong
so let's add a few more
conditions here
all right now we can test our question
again
we get a different version and let's
see what we get when we get somewhere in
the middle
now this is considered partially correct
and
the rating works like this if you get
the red one
you get four points and for each disk
you're awake
you get one point deduction
okay now we've set up
a question with parametrization with
partial grading
but let's look at the feedback now
we have two fields one is the solution
one is the explanation field
the solution is given when
you either did not get it right after a
couple of attempts
or when you get it right at some attempt
in this case we could just type
something like
well done but that would be a very
static message
so instead we can toggle here
and use a expression
so we could say this
is and then pick the right color
disk and we could even show it all right
let's test this
now move here
get it correct and this is
the right disk okay
let's look at the explanation now
remember this is for the case when the
student doesn't get it right
so what we could do here
is just saying
something like you did not find the
right disk but we can go even further
so here we can say you haven't found
the right disk yet and then we can
give tailored feedback by taking into
account
the answer they provided so in this case
we can extract from the given answer the
point
and as we know this is a coordinate we
take the first
the x value again rounded and this gives
us
the number of disks they have
away from the actual solution
let's try this
okay so i move it here in the middle
and this would be
three this away and we get you haven't
found the blue disk yet
move the locator three disk further to
the left
and this is how we can provide tailored
feedback
based on the answer the student provided
and now you have seen all the main
features
in a very simplified way so let me recap
we were able to create different
versions of a question by inserting a
parameter
we randomized the color
based on the list we provided
we set up partial grading
so that each step or
each state could be distinguished
and we provided individualized and
tailored feedback
based on the question based on the
answer the student gave
once the authoring process is completed
we can simply give a name to our
question
and ask rio to deploy
which is as easy as one click
and now what we get is a mylab ready
question
there's so many more things we can do
with creole but let me hand over to
chelsea again to share some feedbacks
from the authors with you
pearson authors are really excited by
the possibilities
eric schultz the co-author of the
calculus e-text we viewed earlier
emailed me late one evening to say that
he had written the mathematica code
which recognizes
multiple parameterization forms for
tangent lines to curves
with free form input to boot multiple
exclamation points
our current mylab exercises will
typically ask for the
standard parametrization for the tangent
line so
this represented a breakthrough for for
him on that particular question
a few days later another note from eric
came in
exercises in the textbook will often ask
questions that we cannot
exactly replicate in the mylab so
consider an exercise that asks the
student to
sketch the graph of a function
satisfying some properties like
increasing decreasing increasing at a
decreasing rate etc on this interval
or that interval i like to call these
the answers may vary exercises since
that's what you would see
in a solutions manual so eric has
coded several new exercises in creo that
allows students to draw these functions
that satisfy
a set of properties and have their
answers graded by
silva so more exclamation points
these are exactly the kinds of exercises
that instructors
and author slash instructors would like
to assign to students but doing so on
paper
is not scalable and doing so in the my
lab is not currently possible
so with these new tools it is and
instructors will have
yet another exercise type that they can
assign to students
that drives that conceptual
understanding
another challenge we face in the my lab
is interpreting
student responses so students use
palettes
in the mylab to enter expressions in a
particular way and the system scores
them very rigidly
on what they entered so
by using creo it allows us to leverage
the linguistic
knowledge of wolfram alpha to interpret
student input to exercises
so consider a randomly generated
exercise where the answer
is sine x the parentheses x
the following inputs in silver would be
accepted as correct
of course sine parentheses x sine with a
capital s
parentheses x sign square brackets x
sine space x sine x no parentheses
so eric did this using
a mathematica command to interpret the
student answer into a precise expression
and then compared it with the correct
answer that has been computed into the
code
so expressions randomly generated
correct answers computed by mathematica
student input parsed using wolfram
linguistic knowledge
and interpreted student answer compared
to the correct answer
and at last credit given in the mylab
this is a seemingly small piece
of the puzzle but this represents a real
improvement for students who can
sometimes feel defeated by the tool
when they've truly understood the
underlying concept it can be
discouraging to be marked incorrect
or a small error like that so bringing
this
the the linguistic knowledge uh to bear
on these exercise types will will be
felt immediately by students and
instructors
so i've really focused on calculus but a
pilot is also underway at pearson
for pre-calculus for linear algebra
and differential equations and the
authors of those titles are equally
enthusiastic about silva's potential
as it will help them bring their
first-rate content from their books
to life for students within the mylab